In just one minute your body produces about 120 to 180 million red blood cells.
Google searches for 2.4 million questions.
25 million Coca-Cola products are consumed.
Many of these bottles will end up in a landfill, where the World Bank estimates we produce 5 million pounds of garbage.
We lose 108 human lives at the moment, and lose 96 million cells.
Fortunately, 96 million cells are divided to replace those lost.
Speaking of divisions: In the USA 1.5 people will be divorced, while around the world 116 people will get married.
83,300 people will practice love, but will only generate 258 children.
The fetal neurons develop at a rate of 250,000 per minute.
So no wonder that computer simulation takes 60 quadrillion bytes to simulate one minute.
The average rainfall in the world is 1.38 micrometers, which is equivalent to filling 4.7 billion tubs every minute.
And with the storms comes nearly 6,000 thunderbolt from the earth fasteners.
And 150 pounds of people consume 1.1 calories per minute of energy during sleep.
While the sun provides about 83.33 TW of energy.
The Earth will move 1,800 kilometers from the 940 million around the Sun, so it moves at a rate of 1034 times faster than the Cheetah.
70,000 hours of Netflix are watched, 300 hours are uploaded to YouTube, you can watch this video and subscribe to the channel.
Translation team translated @autrjim